hey this is presh talwalkar
find the perimeter of a triangle whose
altitudes have lengths of 170 210 and
357
i thank kenji for the suggestion
pause the video if you'd like to give
this problem a try
and when you're ready keep watching to
learn how to solve this problem
[Music]
to solve this problem sketch a triangle
that has altitude lengths of 170 210 and
357
suppose the triangle has side lengths of
a
b
and c respectively
we can calculate the area of the
triangle in three different ways
one is the area is equal to 170 times
the side length a all over two
it's also equal to 210b all over 2
and the area is also equal to 357c
all over 2.
let's solve for the side lengths from
these equations
we'll get side length a is equal to 2
times the area over 170 and we get
similar equations for b and c
from here we will use herron's formula
for the area of a triangle where s is
the semi perimeter
it will be convenient to square this
formula to get rid of the square root
let's solve for the semi-perimeter in
terms of the area
we'll substitute in
and then we will look for the least
common multiple of 170 210 and 357 so
that the side lengths all have a common
denominator of 3570
we can substitute in and then simplify
to get the semi-perimeter is 48a over
3570
we can now substitute into heron's
formula
since everything has a common
denominator it will be easy to calculate
s minus a s minus b and s minus c
it now remains to solve for the area
we just need to simplify this equation
on the right hand side we have the area
to the power of 4 and on the left hand
side it's area squared
so we can cancel out an area squared and
then we can rearrange the equation
we can work with prime factors so it'll
be easy to take the square root
now when we take the square root we have
the area is equal to 3570 squared all
over
336.
we will now substitute this into the
formula for the semi-perimeter which is
equal to 48a over 3570
we substitute in and then simplify to
get the semi-perimeter is equal to 510
the perimeter is equal to twice the semi
perimeter
and therefore it is equal to 1020
and that's the answer
but like a good student we might check
our answer in wolfram alpha we simply
type in triangle with altitude lengths
of 170 210 and 357
wolf prime alpha will tell you
everything about the triangle including
that its perimeter is equal to 1020
so this is a good check on our answer we
did get the correct answer
thanks for making us one of the best
communities on youtube
see you next episode of mind your
decisions where we solve the world's
problems one video at a time